die jungs haben ich muss einmal kurz
unterbrechen und wir schalten zu unserer
kollegin angelika hellemann wenn bei ihr
steht olaf scholz sie hat ihn jetzt im
interview unter hören wir natürlich hier
in unserer runde auch gespannt rein
angelika
scholz die wähler haben entschieden wie
sicher sind sie eigentlich dass sie
wirklich auch der nächste kanzler von
deutschland werden
ich habe sehr früh gesagt dass ich
kandidiere die spd hat mich aufgestellt
und jetzt sehen wir ein ergebnis mit dem
lange viele nicht gerechnet haben die
spd stärkste partei geworden
nach den aktuellen hochrechnungen die
spd kann daraus auch ableiten den
nächsten kanzler zu stellen und ich
merke ja auch dass das was sich in dem
wahlergebnis niederschlägt das zu tun
hat auch mit den umfragen die zeigen
viele wünschen sich auch dass ich die
nächste regierung bilden und führe und
cdu csu sind abgewählt aber herr laschet
aus diesem ergebnis auch irgendwie die
idee eine zukunfts koalition mit fdp und
grünen bilden zu können die balken sind
nach oben gegangen bei den meldungen
über die wahl bei der spd bei den grünen
und auch bei der fdp aber bei der cdu
ganz besonders sind sie massiv nach
unten gegangen das ist eine klare
botschaft der w lan und wlan niemand
möchte dass jetzt eine solche
regierungskoalition zustande kommt also
für sie wäre es ein buch würde ein
verstoß gegen den wählerwillen wenn
armin laschet bundeskanzler werden der
wählerwille ist jedenfalls sehr
eindeutig und deshalb geht es jetzt
darum ganz pragmatisch und sehr
ordentlich darüber zu reden die parteien
zusammenkommen können die dann eine
regierung bilden und da geht es dann
darum dass wir dafür sorgen dass mehr
respekt in unserer gesellschaft herrscht
dass wir die industrielle modernisierung
zustande kriegen die jetzt notwendige
mit wenn ich in zehn zwanzig dreißig
jahren traurig den wohlstand auf anderen
kontinenten zu schauen und es geht
natürlich darum den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
jetzt kommt hier morgen früh das
präsidium und der parteivorstand
zusammen was für ein verhandlungsmandat
wollen sie sich geben lassen
wir wollen schnell eine regierung bilden
wir wollen gute ergebnisse erzielen das
was sich überall auf den marktplätzen in
deutschland gesagt hatte was sich ändern
muss in deutschland das möchte ich auch
der erreichung das halte ich auch für
sehr gut möglich wie schnell müssen sich
denn dann grüne und fdp entscheiden mit
wem sie in koalitionsverhandlungen
einsteigen also ob mit armin laschet
oder mit olaf scholz
es geht darum dass hier alle zusammen
tun und ihren beitrag leisten dass das
was die bürgerinnen bürgern sich
wünschen auch realisiert wird und
deshalb bin ich sicher dass dies ein
klares plebiszitäre votum für eine
regierungsbildung ist um die ich mich
mit anderen parteien bemühen können sie
haben bei der berliner runde jetzt schon
einmal lena werber getroffen und auch
christian lindner haben sie mit denen
noch mal am rande gesprochen oder haben
sie sich schon verabredet wenn sie sich
mal zusammensetzen wollen wir haben uns
schon unterhalten auch nicht nur
öffentlich im fernsehen
und trotzdem glaube ich nicht dass es
sich gehört dass über die dinge die wir
da miteinander bereden jetzt öffentlich
geredet wird aber sie haben heute
miteinander schon gesprochen wie man
oder wann man und wir haben miteinander
geredet
gut jetzt ist es ja aber so dass sie zum
beispiel sagen ohne 12 euro mindestlohn
im ersten jahr ihrer kanzlerschaft das
würden sie so nicht mitmachen wie wollen
sie denn eigentlich christian lindner
dazu bewegen heute abend wird noch
ausgezählt und dann werden wir morgen
uns daran machen wir eine regierung zu
bilden und für mich ist wichtig dass die
dinge die die bürgerinnen bürger sich
wünschen von einer künftigen regierung
auch umgesetzt werden aber
koalitionsverhandlungen führt man mit
möglichen koalitionspartnern nicht in
der öffentlichkeit und haben sie angst
dass die grünen sieht dann erpresst weil
die grünen können ja auch immer
antworten wir können auch jamaika machen
und der armin der gibt uns übrigens
gerade beim klimaschutz sehr sehr viel
mehr das finden wir gerade einfach
attraktiver oder da bekommen wir ein
ministerium mehr meine überzeugung ist
dass politik auch darin besteht dass man
das tut was die bürgerinnen bürger mit
ihrer stimmabgabe von einem erwarten und
ich bin sicher alle werden das sehr
konstruktiv voranbringen ebenfalls ist
dass der auftrag den die heute gekriegt
haben ich werde mich an ihn halten und
ich bin sicher an raum und mit dem
stoßen sie heute abend noch an auf das
wahlergebnis
ich habe schon mit vielen angestoßen
wenn auch mit einem alkoholfreien bier
bisher das gehört ja zum wahlkampf dazu
und zu den großen herausforderungen die
jetzt vor uns stehen und natürlich hoffe
ich dass wenn alles zu ende sich auch
noch mal zeit habe in meiner frau diesen
tag miteinander
aus zu werden
[Musik]